good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van
horn from the university of virginia and i
am delighted to welcome you to this edition of our
2021 2022 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences this year's theme
is ethical challenges of artificial intelligence
and biomedicine where we enjoy presentations
on friday afternoons from leading thinkers
about the promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program have the
opportunity to leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person grant
project development workshop to be held here in
historic charlottesville virginia in june today
i am delighted to welcome our speaker dr marissa
salazar campo from the university of california
irvine marissa is a graduate of stanford
university usc and holds her phd in business
administration from nyu stern school of business
she is an assistant professor of organization
management at organization and management at the
paul marriage school of business her research
focuses on knowledge integration learning and
innovation in interdisciplinary teams she is the
founding president of the international network
for the science of team science as she is the
program director of team science at uc irvine and
ucla and a lead contributor to the team science
acceleration lab at uc irvine in continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science seminar series
theme ritz's lecture today is entitled team
science in big data science bridging the divide
in her presentation murzu will remind us that all
the complexity of scientific problems coupled
with a growing need for specialized expertise
necessitates the formation of teams of experts who
will collaborate across disciplinary boundaries
and generate new scientific breakthroughs the
variety of knowledge available in big data focus
team science provides a breadth of expertise to
tackle these challenges that would be intract
intractable by any single discipline or any
single individual alone the presentation will
demonstrate the use of formal interventions
to support collaborative science across data
and disciplines as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via youtube and
if you're watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially selected 2020
2021 2022 biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are strongly encouraged to submit
any questions for maritza via the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize these
and ask those questions on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and with that
marissa welcome thank you so much for doing this
we are just delighted to hear your lecture today
hi everyone good afternoon it's a pleasure to be
here with you all um i want to give a little bit
of background um with regards to my own journey
and what brings us together here today like like
jack mentioned i am a scholar of organizations and
teams and in understanding what makes a team of
experts into an expert team i've explored a lot
of different worlds than a corporate boardroom
i have been i have worked with the
army research office i have worked
in fortune 500s with teams but i've spent a
good deal of the last 10 years working with
teams in the biomedical biomedical clinical space
as well as with machine learning deep science deep
people who use computer science and machine
learning and so what i bring to you today
is a mixture of what i might present to
a group of business scholars interested
in gaining effectiveness and efficiencies
while also being sensitive to the nuances
of the ventures of discovery and jack mentioned
a couple of different spaces where i you know
show my work and contribute to the intellectual
community and one of them is the international
network for the science of team science
which convenes uh scholars and practitioners
who are interested in understanding how to
support scientific teams the second is around
uci and ucla i provide ongoing consultation to
teams who either want to really kick off well
or who face hurdles along the way and could use
some additional guidance i particularly want to
highlight this team scholarship acceleration
lab which is sponsored by our vice chancellor
for research and you know unless i'm ill-informed
is probably the leading site right now on the web
for guidance about team work at various stages
of formation of various stages of development
and i highly recommend checking out the resources
on that page when you have a chance so throughout
the talk i'll be talking about various aspects
of teamwork leadership and especially bridging
the tools of machine learning and computer science
and various phenomenon i want you to really be
reflecting on your own experiences participating
in teams using big data and analytics and as jack
mentioned please feel free to put your questions
up on the chat if you have questions i'm sure
someone else either here this morning on the talk
or on youtube is struggling with some of the same
uh same of the same challenges or have
the same questions that that you might
okay so i'm going to start with a definition of
what team science is and i say this because across
the national institutes of health the
national science foundation and various
foundations there's an increasing emphasis on
team science multiple pi investigative mechanisms
or developing a management plan
which means that we're getting
we're we're getting to the place where we say gosh
the technical knowledge has got to be amplified
and catalyzed by the ways we interact together
to answer important questions and team science
it's the it's the work that we do collaboratively
to analyze a particular research question about
a particular phenomenon and it is the
case that team science can occur within
a single discipline but more often than not we're
talking about teaming or collaboration across
across various disciplinary or methodological
divides and so this notion and i have this
picture here of albert einstein of the lone
investigator tinkering away by him or herself
in the pursuit of knowledge is in some ways
quite obsolete and i'll actually present to you
some data in support of this view um but what
i will say that um you know i often say with
with scientific discovery that it's so much
about the ways that we in teams even begin with
formulating our problems and you know he often
would say um you know the question shouldn't be
you know what is five plus five but rather how
many different ways could we get to 10 and when
we're in teams with people who have very different
perspectives we're more likely to find divergence
and alternative pathways that just might be our
means to the next big big discovery so here here
you see some data from um scholars who were at the
time out of northwestern where you know they said
gosh it seems like more and more work is happening
collaborating collaboratively is this in actuality
the case and so this work here spans 1975 to
2005 and so we can even anticipate that these
these trends are even greater now but essentially
what it what this data says is that virtually in
all fields research is being done in teams and you
know the exception might be the humanities and the
arts where painting a portrait writing a novel
is still a solo a solo act but what we do see
is that often when people are working together in
teams they're producing work that is high impact
and contributing an important way more than we
see an author working in you know by themselves
in a single domain and with um the work that
i've been able to do um i've had it's been
such a joy honestly a joy to get to work with
scientists who are not necessarily tethered to
you know what their contributions might be in
their own field and right rising to notoriety
from narrow contributions but our truly curious
souls interested in figuring out how we get
closer to solving cancer or reducing obesity
in particular communities or here in california
thinking about how can we better understand
the patterns of forest fires using again
machine learning and so in this pursuit they
have said gosh you know to get to my answer in my
discipline alone i don't see the right frameworks
or i think there are other other methodologies we
could use and it leads them to cross the silos
that often are pretty um difficult to transcend
in our university systems all in the hope that
they're going to be able to answer some of these
really complex health or societal problems and
in drawing together the variety of perspectives
different tools we have seen you know knowledge
synthesis and the creation of of new solutions
so all that to say that there's there's great
promise right and we've even seen at the
um you know throughout the last two years with
the covet pandemic where drawing together um
different kinds of scholars has really led
to rapid discovery of answers or solutions
that being said it is not the case that teaming
across disciplines specialties professions
or geographic locations is a walk in
the park and this data which is also
you know about a decade old took a sub sample
of 500 ns nsf funded projects and they said
all of these projects had great intentions around
teaming and collaboration and they were going
to involve multiple universities and various pis
and if you look at this chart it essentially says
well gosh the more disciplines the more
universities the harder it actually is to
produce knowledge output and those scholars define
knowledge output output as patents publications or
other kinds of products and um so i on the one
hand want to say you know while teaming it's
the way everything is going collaborating
across disciplines it might be the means to
some of our you know again to solve some of our
most intractable problems yet at the same time
when we cross those different chasms we're
going to encounter various challenges
and those challenges come from the inherent
features of team science itself and
uh this figure is drawn from the national
academies of science report on 2 200 2015 which
to my knowledge is the most downloaded um national
academies of science report to date as people are
often trying to figure out how to you know team
better but we have whenever we work together in
in scientific teams we're often looking at fairly
large teams sometimes we're looking at teams of
teams when we look at research centers that have
you know multiple teams embedded within a broader
unit we can have really different goals when
we come together in a team and you know just to
highlight some of my later takeaways from this
talk we you know i've seen in some of my work
where the computer scientist on a team compared
to the scholars that they're collaborating in with
other fields have really different time scales as
to when work is ready to get published and what
contributes a significant um you know addition
to the field relative to other disciplines um
we also have team members coming in and out of
teams right permeable team and group boundaries
we are linked together by phenomena by data
by our office space right we really need to
lock sync our interactions within teams it's
not just like hey i did all this work and
let me pass it back over to you and hands off
we have geographic dispersion and you know i
sometimes show this this slide where we talk about
the difference between the wright brothers making
their simple flying contraption and the number i
think it's 30 plus experts that are ma that are
necessary just to do the engine and a 737 at
boeing but in getting more and more schooling
these days we become specialists in pretty narrow
areas and that narrow specialization makes it even
harder for us to connect to one another and
our expertise um add on to that that we see
um more more gender parity in science we
see people from different backgrounds from
different cultures um people who you know really
just have this high diversity of membership
and it's no wonder right that we have a
hard time working in teams effectively
so um some of these challenges again right
as we go into the practical day-to-day
can be that we you know perhaps we find a couple
of collaborators on our own campuses where we
share a common interest in a particular problem or
societal challenge or empirical area and we want
to get to work and we sit down and we're trying
to coordinate what you know and what they know and
how those pieces fit together in doing so we're
using really different terminology we're using
we're seeing the phenomena from different levels
of analysis and we were trained to do work that
may or may not feel highly compatible on top
of that we get to administrative complexities
and that can come in a lot of different forms
where it's well who's the lead on this project
what percent effort are you if i want to
do a sub award to another campus they're
just all these different pieces that can create
challenges and conflicts as we try to figure out
the legality if you will or the administrative
aspects of working together and then you sit there
and you're going okay i thought this would be
really exciting to go work on this grand challenge
with these new colleagues and this is taking time
this is really requiring a lot of effort when if
i were to stay in my discipline stay with people
who use the same tools publish in the same outlets
i could probably get this work i get some work
done a lot more quickly right where where that
for many of you on the call you'll start to say
gosh i've got to get this many publications before
next year to get tenured and you say forget it
i'm not doing this team teaming collaborative
work until later so it's no surprise right
that often when we do see collaboration and
interdisciplinary teams it's you know scholars
that are a little later on in their career
so you might say to me okay maritza i understand
all these challenges but come on i've you know
i've been on teams forever and we all know we're
all part of different teams we're all doing it
so is it really as tough as you say it is and i
thought i would put this highlight this research
because they're specifically looking at people
that teams that are hoping to do work around
i.t information technology and integrate
computer science with other disciplines and
what this particular paper highlights is that 50
of this sample right 55 pis from 23 institutions
basically write up this beautiful poetic funding
proposal that says we are going to work together
and we're going to collaborate in this way
and the biosketches all seem like they're
you know like pieces of a puzzle
and then they get the funding
and they start working and essentially everybody
goes to their four corners of the campus
and does their work until the progress report
is due nine ten months later and the pi who's a
wonderful writer weaves together a nice little
report but possibly but really these are like
separate independent pieces of work they're
co-acting but not really working together
and i'll explain what that looks like later
the second set is a little more coordinated
and they say hey um we we receive the funding and
we are making sure that we're attending different
talks i'm sharing my work with this other area
they're sharing their findings with the another pi
and they're at least maybe even maybe they share
if this was a bio you know working with some other
samples maybe they're sharing a refrigerator or
a common data set there's something linking them
together that requires a little more coordinated
action around either again a data set talks etc
but this this highest level of integration
where we have scholars coming together
jointly formulating a problem deciding how
they're going to work who's going to work when
maybe even changing their methodologies because
of feedback and information they're gaining
from another colleague this ends up only being you
know roughly a third of the sample that engages in
this integrative cross-disciplinary work despite
everyone saying oh this is what we're going to do
and so um you know i have this question that you
know is it really that elusive to work in this
integrated way and the two studies i just
highlighted say yes it's the outcomes end
up you know our outcome suggests that we struggle
to work across specialty and discipline and then
in practice we often feel more comfortable just
returning back to our home base doing our work
separately and perhaps piecing it together loosely
but i'm going to guess that every single person
on this call and on the internet when you thought
about investing this much time and effort in an
academic career you hoped to understand you
know what what is black matter or how can we
solve this rare disease or right you hope to to
to pursue this this endeavor to make a difference
and for the number of reasons i've just
mentioned it's actually quite hard to socially
and socially interact with our colleagues
in a way that gets us closer to progress
and um what i want to highlight right is that
while you know getting funded getting a lab
is often the product of having a series of papers
and showing technical astuteness that's a really
different skill than learning to lead and
manage a science team and often when i have
different investigators on you know from around
the country really say hey can you help me out
it's you know sometimes it's a junior faculty
but sometimes it's pretty senior individuals um
you know vice vice chairs and chancellor saying
hey this is this is more than i thought i now
have a lab of 10 plus i'm leading a budget of
over a million maybe you know two and i have
uh administrative staff that i'm keeping on
full-time and i am now a manager i'm now creating
workspaces work processes i'm getting updates and
i didn't go to school for this i went to school
to learn how to i learned mathematics
i learned coding not this right and so
some of what you know what what is my you
know why at work and why i do what i do is
to try to say how can i supplement what is you
know the gift of um intellectual prowess with
the leadership and management skills to
really make sure that science teams and
individual collaborators tap into their fullest
potential and don't and end up in that 35 percent
that is able to truly integrate and create new
knowledge by piecing together disparate expertise
and tools in some novel way and so you know what
do i mean when i say effective team scientists
generally i believe that this is about learning
to take a project from formation all the way to
completion and when we have various experts
in the room creating space for all of those
different individuals to share how they see
the problem what they see in data how to create
values like ethics and transparency that enable
people to work in a synchronous way is really key
not to mention that it doesn't take very much
for a team to become factioned and to have us
then dynamics and in particular it's very easy for
computer scientists and data scientists to seem
like you know the means to an end right the
oh well we're the scientists doing the work
and they're just running analysis in this
way on the side and really as many of you on
the call know that's not the case and in fact new
insights can come from the data that can reinform
perhaps the you know the primary
discipline or the content experts
so we want to think about how do we not uh allow
for there to be any discrepancies and power
and status and who deserves a quote-unquote seat
at the table or the time in a in a work meeting
to share what they see and to share what they
know i have this comment here about the ease of
deferring to high status individuals and
groups which can mean you know senior
senior individuals maybe men over women perhaps
people with more technical ability rather than
qualitative skills there's so many different
ways that we let status and hierarchy you know
rear their ugly heads in our scientific teams and
ultimately we end up hearing one dominant voice
and again the science becomes less multiplex and
multifaceted and so ultimately when i walk in and
i to a team a team being led by an individual i'm
looking to say is this a person that is leading in
a way where they're getting participation there's
richness there's a sort of feeling of team flow
around the work itself and do people want to
stay working for this particular individual
especially since it's a choice so uh you know
i i had asked jack ahead of time on campus
or elsewhere i really think that there's value in
seeking out training and development as it relates
to who you are as a leader and how you could lead
more effectively and i'll highlight one example
of the sorts of trainings that i provide and the
reason that these workshops are useful is that you
can gain skills in how you're communicating
how you're leading how you're managing
team processes and even for some of you who are
underneath lead pkis thinking about well how do i
you know manage from the middle or even
from the bottom in terms of making clear
what your role is on a team how your how you
are seeing the work aligning with your pi's
you know six month year plan and making sure
that you're getting what you need from all the
teams that you're a part of and in scientific
teams using big data i also think figuring out
how can we use different tools to make sure that
others can gain access into what we know whether
it's the way we're writing or visualizing either
data or the ways we're going to work together
these can be very very important
to unlocking the potential of teams
and these are just some different examples of the
kinds of um either one-on-one in a way coaching
that i've been able to do with teams and the
research that i've done on various interventions
so um i want to i want to say that you might be
going okay i see that you do a lot in various
areas but what do you really know about data
scientists and our work i just wrapped up a
five-year national research training grant at uci
where we worked with in the end about 60 doctoral
students who were either connect either from the
computer science department doing machine learning
and they were partnered with individuals from
either earth system science chemistry physics
and a little bit in biology and what it meant was
that every trainee that came into our group was
essentially assigned a mentor who was a computer
scientist and a mentor in the other field and it
meant that there was this new frame around what
does it mean to create the transdisciplinary
scholar who's working at the interface between
this novel computer science computer decoding
uh tools and then the particular field context
so we move we you know we we're we're currently
writing up some papers where we're suggesting
that we've got to move away from this notion of
the scholar having a single mentor to them
having a constellation of support systems
that enable them to perform effectively one
of the things that was really useful and
training and developing these scholars was
to create to group them together and micro
communities within their various cohorts
where they were assigned at least one computer
scientist phd and then individuals from the other
disciplines with the hope that they would learn
some new statistical or modeling approach and
then we asked them to present what they learned
to the broader community so examples of this
became we heard we obviously heard about different
machine learning techniques we also learned about
novelty and machine learning and audio and visual
expertise very lots of new approaches were
brought about in this group but what really
mattered i would say is that the scholars were
placed they were giving they were given data
and exposure to new modeling techniques and in
these communities of learning we were able to see
more transfer of expertise from student to student
than we would have even if faculty were giving
presentations from the various departments but as
we prepared these scholars to work with these two
mentors we made sure that they received training
and communicating across disciplines thinking
about how their teams are composed managing
conflict managing their mentor and mentee and also
some basics and where you know tips on
knowledge generation or create you know
generating creativity in their various work teams
and what i what i'm quite proud of is what we saw
we had an external evaluator over time and
we were able to see a pretty significant we
already you know i'll say first of all this
is self-selection any student that chooses
to do this interdisciplinary work already probably
has some sense of efficacy in doing so that being
said we were able to increase their um their
confidence in being able to you know have engage
with others in a positive way interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary way by about seven percent and
then um we really focused a lot on communication
and how they could better interface with their
various mentors and with students in different
different domains i want to highlight though
i'm going to go back here i want to highlight a
couple of takeaways though from watching these
various teams and so in the end we ended up with i
ended up studying 60 different triads of computer
scientists and individuals from the physical or
chemical sciences you know the very first is that
the the students themselves and the the computer
scientists counterparts really did have to roll
up their sleeves and become content experts
and again the the domains included everything
like i mentioned from forest fires to um
patterns of forest fire they basically got
pixel data from nasa to understand changes in
forest fires we looked there was a lot coming
off from linear accelerators data of boson
hicks and other sorts of complex data sets
and the students could not just from an armchair
say oh well you know show me the show me the
pictures of your data or show me send me the
output and i'll run some some some algorithms
on them just wasn't the case and i think we're all
seeing now it's no longer you know 2010 where we
can generally get a phenomenon and try to apply
machine learning approaches i think it is the
case now that one has to become really steeped
in the context or in the phenomena that they're
interested in because the cost can be a risk of
underestimation and quite often as students would
spend a lot of time in a chemistry lab looking
at certain reactions and seeing the output in the
computer data and then needing to code it would
be like oh gosh i didn't understand that there was
this assumption or that assumption that
i didn't i didn't build into my model
um and um and then communicating sufficiently what
was happening with the you know the programming
to the person who was in the other discipline
i i just can't estimate i just can't um you
know overemphasize enough the value
that comes in learning how to simply
convey how a model was built what approaches
what what estimations were underlying a model
etc etc in a way that individuals from the other
discipline could really capture and then on the
other hand making sure that the individuals who
were you know content or context experts also gave
enough of an understanding of the trends and the
nuances and the long-term shifts in what they were
looking at to allow the computer scientists to
have an adequate picture of what the work might be
um and and i i wish i could
say it was a meeting or two but
it's not right it's hours and hours of sitting in
another person's work domain to really understand
uh what it is that they're they're looking at and
i will say i you know i don't have a crystal ball
or anything but i i would say that the students
who you know maybe there might be one or two
content domains that a computer scientist over
the course of their career to really understand
quite well um whether it's some some biological
phenomenon or um there's there's just too much
of a risk of not truly understanding what you
are trying to represent with data and again
i know jack was very interested in ethics
but perhaps misrepresenting the phenomenon
because you're just not sophisticated enough
in your understanding of that phenomenon and
so putting in that time and effort as early
as as in the graduate school years to get
familiar with other phenomena i think is quite
quite important to do ethically sound modeling
uh so i'm going to highlight a little bit about
some recent work that i'm hoping to submit here
in the next couple weeks where um you know what
you say well you know i'm just very interested in
saying how can we help scientific teams produce
more and be more effective and there's a bit
of a bias in the research and that when we see
the successes of scientific teams collaborative
science teams there's bias in that they survived
and they made it through the rough patches and
were able to celebrate their wins and i do know um
you know qualitatively the number of times i see
investigators come together across
campus have a couple of meetings
and then nothing ever really comes of those first
initial points of convening and i wonder well is
there anything that could be done to help in those
formative stages of development to enable scholars
to connect and interlink their knowledge in a way
where they can see oh this is what we could really
do together in a little you know fast track it in
a way and often um you know we in in traditional
management research we have a task right we
need to market this particular product marketing
requires you know people that know a b c and d
let's make sure we staff the team and get to work
the thing about scientific exploration is
there's often a lot of uncertainty about
what we're looking at it's changing all the
time and as a consequence the solution and
who we need to be on the team is also always
changing and i have these images of the covid um
of kovid right because it represents a biological
system that one day we understand it one way
and the next day it's transforming and we're
having to update our models update the ways we
see the problem in order to again find an updated
solution but regardless when we're thinking about
putting some structure to team training when teams
are coming together around problems that have no
clear endpoint to me this is a conundrum where i
say well gosh it's no wonder that so many science
teams never really launch effectively so i wanted
to see where i could i started to sort of look
around for what might be useful in understanding
this problem and i turned to some of the work on
entrepreneurial startups or groups and
then a little bit to the literature and
corporate strategy development and in
both of these literatures you think about
you know how do people bring brand new products
to a market a market that might not even exist
yet because they're about to create it um or
how do companies define strategy when their
environments are always shifting when competitors
are moving pandemics are happening right how
does one plan when there's so many moving parts
and a lot of what this literature suggests is that
you know suggesting that a plan is bulletproof
solid laid out that the steps from start to finish
are very clear is just not practical and rather
what comes up in a lot of these different spaces
is this notion of piecing together a provisional
a provisional plan an initial scaffolding
for hey maybe this is something we
could do and then offering up some
opportunities to probe or test or or essentially
you know hypothesize and say well maybe if we
try this you know the customers will like this or
perhaps if we move in the strategic direction just
in one regional site we can see the effect and
maybe consider and possibly consider that for the
company um you know all around the company so what
my colleagues and i did is we basically built a
um it's about an hour and a half um exercise that
we took teams that had just received some seed
funding to come together after a you know half a
page intent to work together and thought well what
if we bring in an you know an external facilitator
to help build this provisional plan um and and you
know for better for worse we do know that um
teams don't often auto correct and they will
you guys have all been in these situations where
one person talks for the you know the whole
meeting or um you sit there and you go gosh i
didn't really hear what everybody around the room
knows i only heard two or three people talk and
you go to several meetings in a row and you really
just don't know where the team is going so we
thought well perhaps we can create some structure
and help teams identify a potential potential
aim and maybe a couple prototype a couple of
exploratory activities or studies that they could
do to get them on the right track and in doing so
um perhaps do better than uh teams who
do not receive this external support
to um to develop in the early stages and i think
there's a lot of room for this right if we think
about the number of hackathons and boot camps
and um you know maybe even start-up ventures
i think there's a lot of room for thinking about
what can we do to support formation of a team in
these very very very nascent stages and so what we
propose here is that those teams that receive what
we call this provisional planning or scaffolding
intervention are going to be better at knowledge
integration we have a scale for it and we look
at you know their ability to create some outputs
but beyond that we say gosh even in creating
this uh hour and a half not very long exercise
we're going to get we're going to see more
efficiencies where individuals in the room
are going to have a better understanding of what
other people in the room know they're going to
have a faster crystallization of what they're
capable of as a set of prospective investigators
and third when they think about the work they
may want to do they might actually piece together
oh you can do this with you you can gain these
samples or you have this imaging and i have this
you know deep learning approach that i can
apply right and the group will start to
see their potential and in that make it over the
hump of being that you know again team that meets
a couple times and never takes off to actually
crossing that first hurdle to saying you know what
this deserves a spot in my week i think this team
is worth it and the promise of what we could do
together could be worthwhile let's see where this
team goes so we took teams from around the country
who were given pretty small seed award from their
clinical and translational science institutes or
awards and most of these teams were looking
at some sort of biological cause of disease
and we ended up with about 26 different teams
that were randomly assigned either to receive this
external support or not and they worked together
for six to 12 months hoping to submit another
proposal hoping to get some work accomplished and
you know here's a sort of we did a baseline then
we did the intervention we followed up and then we
wanted to see some of the outcomes of these teams
now here's an image from um one team actually
this is in virginia this particular not at not
at your institution but another in virginia
and uh we ask in this exercise that they
put the aims down they think about who needs to
be doing um what work on the team what it takes to
essentially put together a beginning plan of
what everyone could do over time what resources
are available on campus for them to use again
through a series of nine nine steps in the hour
and a half we measured again knowledge integration
we had a couple of different questions things like
by combining what everyone knows on this team did
your team come up with a solution that differs
differs from the way that things are normally
done or the team demonstrated its originality
and its work due to the combined
contributions of its various members
also we we ask them for their traditional measures
of scientific productivity right things like
their publications their funding and their
subsequent grant submissions we measure those
intermediate factors that again the
psychologists like myself are very interested in
um here are some of the mean standard deviations
and and i you know i i'm i understand too the low
sample size relative to
some of you in data science
it's probably appalling but i'm hoping you'll bear
with me to see the gist here which is that we did
find that the teams who receive this intervention
they end up more productive and they end up
integrating knowledge integrating knowledge more
and sure enough they learned more about who knew
what in the team and they gained a better sense
of confidence in what the team could do together
but those two factors did not lead to the
outcomes the only driver that was explained the
relationship between our intervention and improved
knowledge outcomes and knowledge integration was
a better understanding of how everyone's expertise
fits together to accomplish the aim of the group
and here's some of that output data that i
was sharing with you we see higher knowledge
integration and the scaffold intervention we see
they're similar for how much internal money they
go on to ask for from their campuses but take a
look at their external grant submissions almost
every single team in our intervention ended up
being ready to submit a grant in six to 12 months
faster than the other group which will probably
get there but not quite yet at the point of
collecting our last round of data we see
almost twice as many publications and we
also see a higher impact factor from having
just supported again the social interactions
the knowledge sharing processes at the very
beginning of team life which highlights for
me a couple of important things you know one is
that we you know we move beyond this notion of
you know connect pieces of puzzles
that simply need to be adjusted
to recognizing that scientific work is more fluid
flexible and adaptable and this provisional plan
where we literally tell everybody this is not
set in stone let's just talk and hypothesize and
play this is very functional for scientists
to wrap their minds around or investigators
but we also see that maybe just like we you know
we see in child development where imprinting ages
0 to 5 has a particularly strong effect that
perhaps the time the timing of an intervention
for a scientific team early on is really critical
to setting standards of how we should interact and
and how to collaborate and sync our knowledge
together uh you know it's definitely a plug for
not assuming a room of scientists who've all
gotten scientific training is well equipped
to manage social interaction and facilitation
to get to solutions and occasionally bringing
somebody in from the outside to watch how people
are communicating to see how information is being
shared etc i will say that one key that i
will highlight for this particular audience
is as we think about coordination in data science
data sciences i i do think that what i what i
often call a communication covenant could probably
be very useful and especially in combination with
some basic software engineering know-how things
like hey what you know a document that's like
when did you last touch the code what code are you
using how will we indicate versions of code um you
know making sure that there's an understanding as
people are coordinating and synchronizing around
data so that a you know a supervisor a pi can go
into the data and literally see who's done what
i cannot emphasize enough the um the ground rules
for interaction either technically or socially
it's really like the essentials of teamwork that
you just you know if it's not happening in your
lab and this i would maybe spend a day in the
summer just covering hey what are my expectations
for um the ways we interact with the data and
enhance transparency about what needs to get done
um generally for effective you know kind of a
couple of last points um for all the proposals
and works work that you have ongoing it's really
important to always highlight hey who's going to
do what who's responsible for what uh how do
we link together in a project you saw in my
intervention picture that there are
you could visually see the projects
and who was going to be working with whom
really useful for everybody to see the work
identifying how people are going to
interface across different components
and then if you're interested we do have measures
for assessing team team cohesion team integrative
capacity transdisciplinary orientation
i'm happy to share any of those with you
as a leader getting ready to you know go for your
next funding i want to say to you that you have to
showcase yes i can do machine learning yes i can
apply my tools in these novel ways but they're
going to want to see more and more language that
suggests that you have the management skills to
bridge to lead projects to connect different sites
and data points and institutions around big data
and i you know have a couple of some text
in here about ways that people create this
narrative about their soft skills to assure
funders that they're the right person to take on
the quite hairy nature of big data meets complex
phenomena together and if you feel like you could
use a little support there are individuals like
myself where you know you can and i again i
would go to your ctsa and see but you can say
can i put you on for one percent two percent
so that in my management plan i say yep we
have here's our problem here our bio sketches
here's um you know how we're going to work
together but we've also brought on this team
science expert who will be doing our kickoff
who will check in once a month who will be
fine tuning um the ways we interact and and
connect with one another it's okay to to see the
limits of your expertise and bring on others who
can serve as a sort of checks and balance again
catalyzing fast tracking smoothing out
the interpersonal challenges that come up
as we team around quite challenging phenomenon
so um i think with that i just have my last
thank you and if you want to connect on linkedin
you know feel free i'd love to stay in touch
thank you so very much you guys you were talking
you had that early example that you talked about
of the 55 pi and copi project and they were
all gonna it all sounded really great on paper
and then they got the grant and everyone just
kind of like it was just this diaspora of activity
and all that promise for team activities and how
people are going to work together sort of i don't
know kind of didn't happen until the progress
report's due and anyone has to kind of make it up
on the spot which jack you know how it goes
it's like hey send me your paragraphs you send
me your paragraph and i'll weave it together and
make it make it i don't know what you're talking
about i've never been involved in any kind
of project like that but i think it's really
interesting because frank on all honesty i have
and i'm sure that many of the people listening
have been involved with those where it's you know
it's a great idea it looks great on paper and you
were able to convince reviewers and you get the
money and then all of a sudden the team element of
it sort of goes by the wayside and trying to find
ways to kind of maintain that teaminess is super
important and i think some of the ideas you shared
are super important one thing i wanted to to ask
about is one which we're doing sort of right
now on zoom is how is team science affected by
our remoteness now usually you know in team
science it's like if we can all get together
in a conference room and prepare notes so we could
do a post-it slam and we could do all the things
in zoom land it's a little more difficult what
sort of recommendations do you have when we're
kind of working in this way moving forward uh
so i i appreciate the question because i think
the way we we collaborate is always going
to be different moving forward um the the
first comment i have is around this communication
covenant that i mentioned um prior and i think why
that's important is when we don't have the safety
and i mean that in catching our inefficiencies of
walking past each other in the hallway it worked
to say how's that project or where are you on that
we end up with a lot of blind spots and so um
where i think it's useful is to set up a couple of
um best practices right so one is before a zoom
meeting making sure that there is a digital agenda
maybe a google sheet that everyone can
see maybe assigning someone to be a
note capture of what is shared because often it's
hard to facilitate and capture everything that's
being said at the same time yeah having things
like a paper progress spreadsheet where you can
literally go around your lab and say hey where
are we on this where are we on that and then um
and then i would say and this is especially for
you know graduate students and junior faculty
um i would in if you're not meeting regularly
and it was probably more the case in the
height of the pandemic but i would get
in the habit of figuring out does your
whoever it is that you're you know working
with the most do they want an update
uh on paper where maybe it's an email that
says hey as an update this this week i cleaned
this data i built this model i met with these
two other doctoral you know graduate students
um but that's a sort of reporting up so
that you know what it is that's going on
um i do think that a lot of the um when i
would do some various consultation around
campus i did feel that there was less like the
social sciences and other areas where you the
scholars couldn't do their work because
they couldn't physically interact because
of the covid pandemic they were more negatively
impacted than scholars like yourself jack who
the data they could access it
from wherever they they are
but i do think just again having that same
covenant of hey are you working with the
file or am i which changes did you make do
i understand them making sure that there's
a space to ask questions about whatever
phenomenon it is that you're looking at
so that you don't make assumptions and not
accurately capture the complex problem that
you're working on i don't know if that's helpful
at all that that's fantastic you know i mean in
some of what you're touching on there it kind
of was getting to one of my next questions was
a lot of us when we start off in in science
so we have those kind of heady days of being
a post doctoral researcher and we're
really like our nose is just like up in
against the computer screen we're doing
all sorts of really cool data analytics
and we've become assistant professors or more
senior professors for some of us and we we stopped
really doing that kind of intense scientific
investigation and we've become kind of the
you know the managers the middle management ceo
of the van horn enterprise for example and you're
trying to make sure that people are supported that
they have the resources they need and that their
uh if there's any challenges that they're overcome
and that it becomes the dominant thing in one's
life and i think you're absolutely right when you
said that we didn't train to do that stuff no no
and actually jack when i have individuals and some
of which you know we know fairly closely in common
they will come at that point in their
career and say i'm buried in admin
and i think i could find ways to become more
efficient at it because why i am in this career
is to answer big questions and if i look at my
average work week i'm barely getting to them
and even in that space when we think about what
leadership is in a scientific team it's too
it's to see not with our eyes but to
have vision into the next scientific
um area of inquiry right to be the next the first
ants at the next big space to do important work
and one cost to me when i hear senior people like
yourself saying that is where is your play at so
that you can take your lab into new spaces
they never could have thought possible but
because you saw it first the lab was in a great
position to be doing whether it's visual ai or
you know i don't i don't really know what the
next you know big corner might be but um where
were they sort of like reading and exploring just
stops as a cost of so much administrative work
in certain areas of team science there might
be some bottlenecks they could be bottlenecks
of communication it could be bottlenecks of just
kind of the cold start problem or what have you
um do you see like data science playing a role
in helping to kind of like push through some of
those more expeditiously uh i do and that i think
like i was just listening to a talk on uh health
health equity health inequities and big data and
i think if there's there's some real opportunities
in highlighting again kind of like that um where
should the where would work be most fruitful next
and i do think that they're patterns and
areas that machine learning can really
be important in that area in terms of bottlenecks
i mean i can't i can't say unfortunately i feel
like sometimes it might be an assuming others
on your team have coded a particular way that
there's no mistakes in the way in the
language they're using and moving forward
only to go oh no two weeks ago there was
something done that shouldn't have been done
and having again the ethics and the the sense
of value to be like we have to stop and go back
we've got to fix it and make it right when the
pressure to get things done and to manipulate
data because who's really going to know how to
check it or fix it i mean i i saw a lot of my
graduate students really struggle with the sort of
phishing or manipulation of big data because it is
sometimes so easy to do but the bottleneck
will be who's willing to say hey we've gotta
we've gotta do this right let's go back a couple
weeks let's fix this and then move forward um
any reactions to that answer jack well i was
going to say that you touched on something about
students and the role where students can you know
today as which is completely different than how it
might have been 20 years ago is that team science
is almost baked into the type of work that we
do how can we make sure that students are being
further trained and educated about the best ways
to be uh to leverage team science in an ethical
way um and how can we do that better so that
when you get to a situation like the one you
describe it's just yep that's exactly what we do
we go back and we unspool the problems that
we've created and we find that that trouble
point and then fix it and move forward
again how do we do that best yeah that's
where that's where when i say leadership
is very much about walking the walk and
in in recognizing that for many you were like
they're the first parent right when they work
for you in the lab and they're watching
and they're saying how does my advisor this
assistant professor that's so smart so bright how
do they handle and they see all the various events
and that becomes their code of conduct their
way of working and it's i think it's a personal
a personal promise and commitment to say i'm going
to run my data science lab in a way that's upright
here's our standards for you know how we
manage data when we say i've got to raise my
hand and say stop the presses we need to check
this check that like it's in your behavior that
you're that the this generation and the
subsequent generations of data scientists
will learn how to do work transparently fairly and
ethically absolutely and thank you marisa salazar
campo from the university of california irvine
for sharing your thoughts with us today this was a
wonderful discussion thank you i really appreciate
it thank you everyone you too bye everyone see